ich möchte mit einem thema heute
anfangen das mich wahnsinnig aufgeregt
hat als ich heute morgen aufgewacht bin
und gehört habe dass berlin ist man
wieder gar nicht hinbekommen hat der
absolute saustall der chaos ort berlin
mich hat das andy ost ukraine erinnert
als ich dort das letzte mal einen
referenten und gecovert habe und zehn
stimmen auf eine seite gegen in berlin
war es so dass bürger plötzlich die
eigentlich eu ausländer sind abstimmen
konnten über die bundestagswahl dieser
fehler ist passiert weil alle wahlzettel
in einen umschlag gegangen sind nicht
nur dass auch minderjährige durften
plötzlich bei der bundestagswahl
abstimmt ich finde wir reden viel zu
wenig darüber was hier in berlin
passiert und was bei dieser wahl
passiert ist denn eigentlich müsste
diese wahl hier in berlin zumindest
dringend wiederholt werden
jaaa powell wir reden wir reden viel
darüber das ist ja gerade das problem
wir reden viel darüber aber auch so und
es tun sich offenbar keiner denn das
sind eklatante versäumnisse die wir hier
sehen und wir haben sie am wahltag du
hast es am wahltag beschrieben die
menschen vor den wahllokalen standen
stundenlang ältere menschen die dann
nach hause gegangen sind die gar nicht
mehr gewählt haben und gar nicht mehr
abgestimmt haben wären stimme also durch
dieses wahlchaos unbrauchbar wurde und
das ist eigentlich fatal weil wir
natürlich aus amerika diese diskussion
kennen von der letzten
präsidentschaftswahl wo wahlen in frage
gestellt worden sind aufgrund von
verbindungen hier und da gegeben hat
aber die legitimität einer solchen
demokratischen wahl darf nicht durch
solche versorgung des in frage gestellt
werden und ein punkt noch dazu es war ja
dann so dass man versucht hat die
wahlleiterin in schutz zu nehmen und zu
sagen da ist ja gar nichts passiert gott
sei dank musste sie dann zurück drehte
aber wir sehen das chaos hat nicht
geendet mit ihrem rücktritt es geht
immer weiter
erstaunlich finde ich wie viel berlin
dann doch noch geregelt kriegt
mittlerweile vier dax konzern hier fast
so viel wie in münchen man fragt sich
woher berlin diese kraft nimmt bereits
zu etwa einen von den 3 das würde uns
sehr das würde ich sehr freundlich sagen
nein ich denke einfach was wäre möglich
in berlin wenn man die wirtschaft noch
mehr stärken würde wenn es in diesem
chaos schon gelungen ist hier vier
dax-konzerne groß zu machen aber das
sind ja startups die groß gebauten sind
keine gewachsene industrie insofern
frage ich mich wenn man andere weichen
nicht stellen würde was sich hier alles
noch entfalten wird alexander kissler
bei der neuen züricher zeitung mit dem
blick so ein bisschen von außen auch gut
wenn sie selbst deutsche sind was denkt
man wenn man im büro der neuen züricher
arbeitet und auch mit den züricher hin
und her kommuniziert über das was in
berlin passiert ist also kein thema ist
das so beliebt wie also eine freund
berichterstattung aus berlin man glaubt
einfach nicht was hier möglich ist wird
man sich auch hier gewöhnt hat man
glaubt vor allem gegen sich an das
achselzucken mit dem wir noch die
größten pannen tolerierten akzeptiert
werden ein br dauer zehn jahre länger 15
jahre länger eine milliarde 2 milliarden
3 milliarden erwirtschaften ist zwar
nicht aber dank des
länderfinanzausgleiches haben wir es ja
dass diese berliner wurschtigkeit man
regt sich schon gar nicht mehr darüber
auf auch jetzt hier greift diese
wirklichkeit ja über berlin hinaus indem
er einfach sagt bis zum
bundesverfassungsgericht weil dieses
thema zu hören ja es gebe ja gar keine
mandatsverschiebung dadurch dass dadurch
dass nicht alle stimmen abgegeben worden
sind da kann ich nur sagen ein päckchen
packen also ich habe noch gelernt one
man one vote ist demokratie ich bin
bereit das heute auf volumen von bord zu
erweitern aber ich bin nicht bereit zu
sagen wir schätzen wie viele leute
gewählt haben und wenn es irgendwo noch
mandats auswirkungen hat dann lassen wir
es gelten dann könnte man auch sagen wir
lassen gleich eben einen schimpansen ein
ergebnis werfen mit dem das pfeil und
danach kann man sagen ja das war es
vielleicht auch hier die
schwarmintelligenz zu berlin passt also
ich finde das geht einfach nicht diese
nonchalance berlin bekommt wenig hin ich
habe vor einem jahr buch geschrieben
infantile gesellschaft um ein
hauptakteur war die kindische metropole
berlin aber was mich noch mehr aufregt
und das ging einfach in der schweiz
einfach nicht dass man es so hinnehmen
dass man sagt funktioniert es ist aber
so berlin
nina du du bist solltest seit ungefähr
einem jahr in berlin und wenn nur halb
fühlst du dich jener wüste oder auch ich
vermisse ich das ja schon sehr in berlin
ist nicht meine traumstadt letzte letzte
woche freitag
der begriff fällt state gesagt mit blick
auf berlin das fand ich ganz passend
aber zu dem thema wahl darauf
zurückzukommen ich finde die wahl das
war auch ein großartiger kommentar von
unseren chefredakteur julian reichen
natürlich
dass wir in seesen deswegen ich hab es
bei julian gelesen und da kann man ja
auch mal man darf ja auch mal ruhig
chefredakteurin direkt ein schleimer zu
sein ich bin lieber ein schleimer als
annalena baerbock die copy cat jetzt ist
es doch alle auf die grünen gezwungen
beliebt über
hat er da über die über diese dieses
große los dieses größte glück der wahl
aufgeschrieben und wie sehr es ein ja
auch bewegt und ich habe mich in diesem
kommentar komplett wieder gefunden wer
bei uns zuhause zb ist familiensache
solche meine schwester und ich habe
jetzt gemeinsam die briefwahl gemacht
weil ich nur die briefwahl machen konnte
und ich finde diese wahl ist was großes
und ja ich fand ich finde das deswegen
dass berlin damit einfach umgegangen ist
es kann nicht sein also jedes ist muss
ja auch den menschen gezeigt werden wie
ist immer ein großer tag demokratisch
und der der große tag der demokratie
wurde eigentlich mit füßen getreten
werden drei tage fordert denn auch wovon
bundespräsident steinmeier gehen sie
wählen hoch an der demokratie jede
stimme zählt machen sie von ihrem recht
jahr auch das andere bieter erkämpfen
mussten wir auch in unserer geschichte
aber berlin sagt neuer wellness
glückssache nun gibt es aber keinen so
großen unterschied zwischen rheinland
und bei denen ich bin ja selber
rheinländer und düsseldorf und berlin
das sind schon welten die die sind auch
wirklich von der mentalität ganz
unterschiedlich allerdings gibt es in
berlin ja ganz viele menschen die hier
hingekommen sind aus ganz
unterschiedlichen kulturkreisen und die
hier leben und ich lebe hier nicht mehr
ich lebe jetzt in münchen auch eine
tolle stadt aber ich habe nie so lange
gelebt in einer stadt wien berlin und
ich habe dieses berliner empfinden wenn
jemand über berlin her zieht dann stürzt
weil diese stadt hat so viel mitgemacht
hat sich so toll irgendwo raus wieder
entwickelt dass ich das nicht gut ab
kann aber solche verwaltungsfehler her
was über münchen sagen wer aber auch was
negatives ja aber
also insofern bin ich es nicht mehr wenn
man alles was in dieser stadt falsch
läuft einfach ein update auf die stadt
selbst das sind wir handeln habe aber
das spannende ist doch mal ein bisschen
anderen ich stell mir das mal vor wir
hätten über eine wahl berichtet in einer
weiß nicht in afrika hatten wo auch
immer ja und wir bei bild hätten darüber
berichtet dass es möglich gewesen ist
dass hier zum beispiel ein deutscher
dort hätte wählen können ja
riesenaufregung und dann hätte man doch
gesagt um gottes willen wo waren denn
die osze wahlbeobachter und wieso ist ja
nichts passiert also bilder hat ja auch
gerade angesprochen warum sie keine
konsequenzen dafür sogar minderjährige
haben gewählt ausländer haben gewinn
kein problem ja okay jetzt reden wir
wieder über die koalition droht ihr
körperlich war ja ich werde hier als
offizielle wahlbeobachter der
schweizerischen eidgenossenschaft aber
ich muss ja auch ein bisschen der hat
jetzt konkurrent ich musste nie solo den
ball muss ein bisschen nachdem weder
unterricht gebe ich meine wir sind uns
einig da dieses rot-rot-grüne regime wir
haben das nicht unbedingt den nobelpreis
wie kompetenz gewonnen an diesem sonntag
aber um den ehrenbürger von berlin zu
zitieren napoleon bonaparte der durch
das brandenburger tor marschiert ist er
hatte gesagt unterschied sie nie den
faktor
inkompetenz in der politik so gesehen
müssen wie dieses wahldebakel als
realitätsschock als heilsamen
öffentlicher als auch ein schoko eis
passiert dann auch nichts war vielleicht
auch nicht so schlimm aber ich muss
sagen berlin da muss ich als
vehementesten widersprechen berlin ist
also ziemlich schon eine traumstadt ich
finde das großartig ist in den letzten
paar jahren ein bisschen mehr versucht
worden das muss ich sagen aber wenn wir
uns jetzt vor augen führen in der großen
historischen betrachtung wofür steht
nämlich im kollektiven unterbewusstsein
des schweizers um viele europäer berlin
dann ist das die pickelhaube dann ist
das das zentrum des preußischen
militarismus immer schon ein
missverständnis weil die berlin viel
vielschichtiger war aber so gesehen sehe
ich in diese oder inkompetenz in diesem
wege groove sehe ich sozusagen die rache
der geschichte das ist jetzt einfach
dass die pendler schlage ins gegenteil
von der pickelhaube in die rot-rot-grüne
inkompetenz und irgendwann bin ich
zuversichtlich werdet ihr auch von der
bild zeitung von der nz dafür sorgen
dass wir wieder den vernünftig den
mittelweg gehen und deshalb bin ich auch
ein bisschen häufiger wieder in berlin
um ihren bisschen vernunft habe die
ganze geschichte hinein zu bringen
[Musik]